DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS WAS
REFUSED SERVICE AT A RESTAURANT.
HE MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT.
IT WAS A MEAN THING TO DO BUT IN
A NEW ERA WHERE MEAN GIRLS RULE,
SOME MEAN GIRLS THINK IT'S A
PLUS.
JENNIFER RUBIN WROTE A PIECE ON
THE LOST ART OF SHUNNING.
SHE FEELS FOR THE RESTAURANT
OWNER.
JENNIFER, SHUNNING NOT A LOST
ART.
IT WAS ONCE USED TO OSTRACIZE
PEOPLE FOR RELIGIOUS REASONS.
IT'S EXTREMISM.
JENNIFER HATES TRUMP AND
EVERYONE LINKED TO NAME SOME OF
THE EXTREMISM IS WARRANTED.
MEANWHILE, MAXINE WATERS WANTS
DEPARTMENT STORE, ATTIC GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET UP AND CREATE A
WELCOME.
>> Greg: YOU'RE NOT WELCOME AT
WORK WE SAW IT STARTED.
>> IF YOU VOTE FOR TRUMP, THEN
YOU, THE VOTER, ARE STANDING AT
THE BORDER LIKE NAZIS GOING YOU
HERE, YOU HEAR.
WE HAVE TO FLIP IT.
GIVEN THE EVILNESS OF
DONALD TRUMP BUT IF YOU VOTE
COMEDIC NO LONGER SUPPORT
YOURSELF.
A >> Greg: WHAT A DOPE.
WHY IS THE GUY YELLING NAZI
OFTEN BEST IN IMITATING ONE.
SHUNNING, HARASSMENT,
NAME-CALLING, VIOLENCE.
OR COMING RIGHT TO YOUR HOME TO
TERRIFY YOUR FAMILY.
>> FREE THE KIDS.
FREE THE KIDS.
SHAME, SHAME, SHAME.
>> Greg: WHAT IF SHUNNING WENT
BOTH WAYS.
WHAT IF COPS IGNORED 911 CALLS
BECAUSE OF POLITICS?
WHO DO YOU THINK THE POLICE
SUPPORTS MORE?
NANCY PELOSI OR DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S AN EASY GUESS.
BUT THE POLICE WOULD NEVER, EVER
DO THAT BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT
IT MEANS TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
WHAT IS AS BAD AS SHUNNING?
HOW ABOUT DESIRING A PERSON'S
PRESENCE AT AS HIRED HELP.
THE TRIBALISM AMONG RESTAURANTS,
THE LEFTISTS SNARKED WHO IS
GOING TO COOK AT REPUBLICAN ONLY
RESTAURANTS?
THEY EXPECT THEM TO VOTE THEIR
WAY BUT ONLY AFTER THEIR SHIFT
IS OVER AND THE QUESTION.
SHOULD MAXINE WALK IT BACK?
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK SHE'S
GOING TO BUT NANCY PELOSI TRIED
TO.
SHE TWEETED THAT IT WAS
UNACCEPTABLE AND SHE WANTS TO
MAKE AMERICA BEAUTIFUL AGAIN.
SHE DID TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
PEOPLE ARE REACTING TO SOMETHING
BUT SHE WAS NOT FOR THE
INSTABILITY.
NEWS NOW, MAXINE WATERS YEARS
AGO IN HER DISTRICT, IT WOULDN'T
OF BEEN FRONT PAGE NEWS EVER BUT
NOW YOU DO RUN THE RISK OF
SOMEONE LIKE MAXINE WATERS
PAINTS EVERYONE WITH A BROAD
BRUSH.
WHAT SHE IS DISCUSSING SOMETHING
UNHEALTHY AND OBNOXIOUS.
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
PEOPLE WHO THINK THIS IS GOOD,
WE ARE CREATURES WHO WANT TO
SURVIVE.
IF YOU FEEL CORNERED, YOU FIGHT
BACK.
IT COULD ESCALATE QUICKLY.
>> Greg: JUAN, AM TORN ABOUT
THE RESTAURANT THING.
OR RESTAURANT, IS IT MORE OF AN
ACCEPTED PROCESS BECAUSE THAT
STANCE IS NO LONGER TETHERED TO
HARDSHIP.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE '60s.
IF I SAY YOU CAN'T COME IN HERE,
IT MIGHT THE ONLY RESTAURANT IN
WAS NOT AS HARD TO FIND IN THE
PLACE TO GO?
DO YOU FOLLOW ME?
>> Juan: I DIDN'T BUT I'M
'60s IT WAS OVER RACE.
SUPER K CREATED A REAL HARDSHIP.
>> Juan: THERE WERE BLACK
RESTAURANTS TO GO TO IN THE
'60s.
IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY IN THE AS
SENSE THAT THERE'S THAT
TREMENDOUS AND SAID HISTORY IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD SAY
THERE'S HISTORY OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS BEING EXPORTED FROM
RESTAURANTS.
A >> Greg: I SAYING IS THAT
OKAY NOW THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
OPTIONS IN GENERAL FOR PEOPLE
THAT IF YOU SAY I DON'T WANT YOU
IN MY RESTAURANT, YOU CAN GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
NANCY PELOSI,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," DAVID
AXELROD SAID IT.
AXELROD SAID TRUMP HAS REALLY
BEEN ROUGH IN TERMS OF HIS USE
OF LANGUAGE AND     AND THE THIG
OF LANGUAGE AND     AND THE THIS
OF LANGUAGE AND     AND THE THIH
OF LANGUAGE AND     AND THE THI'
OF LANGUAGE AND     AND THE THIS
ENCOURAGED HIS SUPPORTERS TO DO.
BUT IT'S NOT A REASON, IT
DOESN'T JUSTIFY THE LACK OF
CIVILITY OR RUDENESS TO PEOPLE
WHO YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT POINT
OF AGREEMENT WITH.
IT WOULD LEAD US DOWN THE ROAD
HERE WHERE WE REDUCE OURSELVES
TO TRIBALISM AND WE ARE SHOUTING
AND SCREAMING AT EACH OTHER.
BREAKING APART OUR COMMON BONDS
AS AMERICANS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF TRIBALISM
AND TRUMP, JESSE, I DO THINK
THING HE DID, IT WAS DIRECTED TO
OTHER REPUBLICANS FOR THE
LONGEST TIME.
IT WASN'T AN IDEOLOGICAL ORIGIN.
>> Jesse: I DON'T SEE THAT
SIMILARITY WITH THAT RESTAURANT
THING.
LIKE YOU SAID, IT YOUR
LIBERTARIAN.
I THINK THIS BEHAVIOR PLAYS INTO
DONALD TRUMP'S HANDS.
LAST COUPLE YEARS UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, YOU HAD
ANTIFA, RACIAL RIOTS, OPEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED TO
CLEAN UP THAT KIND OF MESS IN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FUNDAMENTALLY ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
THEY WANT OTHER PEOPLE TO BE
RESPECTED, AND THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO TOLERATE RAGE-
IF YOU SAY DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
CABINET ARE NAZIS, IT'S GOING TO
INCITE PEOPLE TO TREAT PEOPLE
PUT THEIR LIVES IN DANGER.
THE NAZI COMPARISON IS LAZY,
HISTORICALLY INACCURATE, IT
MEANS THEY'VE LOST THE ARGUMENT.
I BELIEVE IT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
TRUMP IS WINNING, NOT LOSING,
AND THIS IS DRIVING THE LEFT
CRAZY.
HE IS SECURING THE BORDERS, AND
THAT'S A THREAT TO THE LEFT.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE IT.
THEY ARE NOT ACTING LIKE THEY'RE
ACTING LIKE THEY ARE DESPERATE.
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE LEFT.
THEY ARE LITERALLY MELTING DOWN
BEFORE OUR EYES, THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT CAN
CONTROL THEM.
AND IT'S JUST HELPING
DONALD TRUMP SUCCEED.
HIS NUMBERS AS RECORD HIGH RIGHT
NOW.
>> Greg: CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER
WITCHES COME AS A CONSERVATIVE,
WE THINK THEY ARE WRONG BUT THEL
WE THINK THEY ARE WRONG BUT THEF
WE THINK THEY ARE WRONG BUT THET
THINKS WE ARE EVIL.
IF THEY THINK YOU'RE EVIL, THEY
CAN DO ANYTHING TO YOU.
IF THEY THINK YOU ARE NOT TO
COME, AND MORALLY THEY ARE RIGHT
LEVEL OF VITRIOL IN THE RHETORIC
FAMILY, TO BE ABLE TO SOMEONE
YOU CAN'T EAT HERE AT THIS
RESTAURANT.
YET THEY FIGHT FOR THE CASES
LIKE THE GAY RIGHTS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A WRITING CAKE MADE OR
SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE, IT'S A
SOMETHING LIKE THE DEVIL, THEN
THEY ARE SAY THEY ARE JUSTIFIED
IN DOING IT MORE LAND ETHICALLY.
CALLING FOR THIS ARE CALLING TO
PUT A CHILD IN A CAGE WITH
PEDOLPHILES, AT ATTACKS AGAINST
FAMILIES CAN YOU IMAGINE SARAH
SANDERS OR HER FAMILY GOING INTO
HER RESTAURANT, SAYING YOU CAN'T
EAT THERE.
IT'S GOING BACK IN TIME.
IT'S NOT MOVING FORWARD IN TERMS
OF CIVILITY IN DISCOURSE AND
DISAGREEING WITH SOMEONE RATHER
THAN HATING THEIR GUTS AND
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE WHAT YOU
STAND FOR.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THIS
STARTED BEFORE.
I THINK A LOT OF THIS IS OUT OF
TRUMP'S RHETORIC IN THE WAY
UNDER OBAMA.
I DON'T REMEMBER THIS HAPPENING
UNDER, EVEN WHEN THERE IS ANGER
AT GEORGE W. BUSH ABOUT NOT
FINDING WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
I DON'T REMEMBER THIS KIND OF
ACTING OUT ON EITHER SIDE.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE NOW I THINK
HIS PEOPLE FOCUSING ON THIS AND
NOT ON THE POLICY.
PROBLEM BUT CRYING CHUCK SCHUMER
DO NOTHING ABOUT IT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP FOR
PEOPLE TREATING THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK FOR HIM LIKE ANIMALS.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> Juan: TRAIN THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK FOR HIM.
>> Jesse: WHEN PEOPLE PROTEST
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS YOU CAN'T
BLAME THAT ON DONALD TRUMP MODE
YOU JUST DID.
THAT'S UNFAIR.
IT'S ON THEM, NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Jesse: IF YOU GO TO A
DONALD TRUMP RALLY AND
DONALD TRUMP IS SAYING I WILL
PAY LEGAL FEES IF ANY OF YOU
WANT TO BEAT UP PEOPLE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Jesse: WE KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE SWINGING OR PAID
PROTESTERS.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP SAYING IF
HILLARY CLINTON IS ELECTED AND
APPOINTED A SUPREME COURT JUDGE
AND DOES ANYTHING TO YOUR GUN
RIGHTS, YOU SECOND AMENDMENT
COME ON.
>> Jesse: THERE HAS BEEN --
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU CALL THE
LADY GETTING RUN OVER IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE?
>> Jesse: I WOULDN'T BLAME
DONALD TRUMP FOR THAT.
I BLAME THAT INDIVIDUAL.
>> Juan: THEN HOW DO YOU BLAME
THE RESTAURANT OWNER?
NOBODY IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
TOLD HER RESTAURANT OWNER WHAT
TO DO.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY UP AND CALLING
TRUMP A NAZI.
AND LIKE MAXINE WATERS SAYING I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO REFUSE
PEOPLE SERVICE.
>> Greg: I THINK THE WHAT